depuis l'arrivée de l'épidémie de
coronavirus dans nos vies en février
dernier les alliés de notre quotidien
sont désormais les gestes barrières les
masques et bien entendu le célèbre hall
gel hydroalcoolique gel hydroalcoolique
gel hydroalcoolique le gel hydro
alcoolique est aujourd'hui partout dans
nos vies il serait une arme essentielle
dans la lutte contre la propagation du
virus
sauf que voilà aujourd'hui certains de
ces gènes vendus dans le commerce serait
totalement inefficace et il ne s'agit
pas que de quelques flacons la direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes
la dgccrf a mené une sérieuse étude
nationale en réalisant 162 prélèvements
73% des produits analysés à ce jour ont
été déclarés soit non conformes dans 38%
des cas soit non conformes et dangereux
pour 35% d'entre eux des chiffres qui
insiste sur le manque d'alcool dans ces
produits
l'alcool est l'agent qui tue les
bactéries mais aussi celui qui est le
plus coûteux dans la confection des gels
souvent la raison pour laquelle
certaines marques en font l'économie
un acte qui peut s'avérer très dangereux
pour la santé pour être efficace contre
le coc vide les gels hydroalcooliques
doivent contenir au moins 60% alcool des
millions de flacons de gel seraient
concernés bruno fellous pharmacien est
avec nous pour nous en parler alors
certains gels hydroalcooliques dangereux
est ce un scandale et oui certains gels
hydroalcooliques sont dans leur merci
bruno flou d'être avec nous on vous voit
d'ailleurs chez jean-marc aussi un mort
en initiaux monde tiens il ya une
question qui vient de tomber pour vous
rené maleville
bref ahmad ezz qui croient que des
vannes rené si le professeur house
orthez 1
elle sortait un vaccin un vaccin est ce
que vous feriez vacciner c'est des gens
qui vous pose cette question non non non
non non non non mais quand même les
mêmes des années parce que moi j'ai pas
qu'on vienne et les vaccins de suite je
pourrai seul moyen de hockey donc oui
c'est le professeur raoul ou parce que
bonne question parce que c'est vrai
qu'on dit qu'il a le mérite d'avoir
essayé où l'émetteur match à lyon contre
lui la plupart vous moi je critique pas
il a le mérite d'avoir essayé un
traitement peut-être ça a marché
peut-être ça va marcher en a qui ont
essayé à priori faire fonctionner
aujourd'hui il ya peut-être d'autres
traitements frisé sur un cd vendus la
chloroquine vous dans votre pharmacie on
a demandé beaucoup mais nabucco et au
début du confinement on a on a nous a
demandé d'ailleurs ça a été interdit à
la vente
ils ont bloqué la vente de la
chloroquine après pour ceux qui devaient
en prendre parce qu'il ya des gens qui
étaient en traitement de chloroquine les
avait une ordonnance très spécialisés et
qu'elle a envoyés au laboratoire puisse
vendre de la chloroquine mais ça a été
arrêté pendant quelques mois où nos
journaux vous qui êtes pharmacien la
chloroquine vous y croyez comme
traitement la chloroquine moi je suis
pas médecin je suis pas le chercheur je
suis pas infectiologues
mais elles existent sur le marché depuis
des années à savoir que avant décembre
elle était elle était en vente sans
ordonnance donc après il n'y avait pas
autant de polémiques que ça sur ce type
de médicaments elle est passée en 2020
sur ordonnance pourquoi je ne sais pas
elle peut avoir des effets indésirables
si elle est mal prise il faut avoir un
suivi médical faire des radios oui
maintenant est-ce que c'est dangereux je
ne sais pas moi de le dire je veux pas
ça vous reconnaissez le stif alors j'ai
entendu le stif
oui le spliff ce prix non je vais vous
dire ce que c'est
le stif parce que voilà on m'a dit que
c'était donc un téléspectateur c'est la
société de pathologie infectieuse de
langue française
c'est l'association loi 1901 regroupant
les professionnels de la santé et donc
c'est le stif qui attaqueraient didier
raoult les calculs c'est le projet
d'accord donc le spis la danse
bruno
il ya une étude qui vient de sortir qui
dit que les gels hydroalcooliques serait
dangereux à 13%
ça ça fait peur à tout le monde
aujourd'hui ça a été le gros sujet du
jour donc c'est grave quand même c'est
la question donc qu'on vous pose on peut
la mettre derrière si au ps vous choqué
par les révélations sur le gel
hydroalcoolique vous dites oui on va
voir la réponse de bruno un instant oui
bien entendu
après mon moi je suis choquée parce
qu'on nous vend des trucs qui sont
potentiellement dangereux et qui nous
protège pas moi j'avais donné un exemple
ici parce que comme je le traîne quand
je travaille j'ai les mains beaux habits
mais toutes là toute l'année on dit
qu'il faut y avoue me dit je me trompe
faut avoir 73 % d'alcool dans le jet de
60 à partir de 63
donc il ya de l'alcool dedans
normalement si tu prends d'un gel et que
tu met de l'alcool sûreté makusha une
flèche normalement ça doit te problème
j'ai lu l'étude
je me suis renseigné la chair le
problème et c'est pas les 63 % d'alcool
ses caves et des gels au début de camp a
pu on a dû s'approvisionner au regel qui
étaient pas conformes ont été la
conformité des gels hydroalcooliques n'a
démarré que après confinement quand la
rs a commencé à chercher
qu'est-ce qu'on a importé pour avoir
déjà il faut savoir qu'il y avait une
pénurie de gel en france donc tous les
pharmaciens ou toutes les personnes qui
pouvaient éventuellement vente du jem
ont s'approvisionner à droite à gauche
sans trop regarder la proposition d'un
gel hydro alcoolique mais ajuste brûle
quand on dit ça peut être dangereux
non mais ça veut dire que ça peut
provoquer quoi c'est ça qui nous fait
peur en fait non mais dangereux de toute
façon tous produits que vous mettez sur
la peau à haute dose et hérite n'irrite
un petit peu la peau donc c'est normal
même un gel normal un gel
hydroalcoolique conforme avec un taux
d'alcool pur conforme aux à la
composition brûle un peu la peau c'est
normal mais surtout c'est ça le problème
non mais si à l'alcool à 63 % quand vous
avez un j'ai associé compensant ça
suffit et puis c'est la norme
c'est un an jean michel merle et les
éduque que ça soit il n'est que certains
soient inefficaces
on est d'accord c'est vrai qu'on dans la
précipitation et a certainement des
règles avaient été respectées inefficace
mais qu'en dit c'est dangereux c'est pas
parce que c'est dangereux pour la santé
c'est parce que c'est pas écrit sur la
bouderie que c'est un produit
inflammable si évidemment faut être un
peu à ça va bien sûr c'est pour ça
en fait un peu de débit pour mettre de
l'hydro et que l'hydrogène pas quoi le
colis cas au dessus d'une flamme
c'est pour ça que ça a été consacrée aux
yeux vont toucher les yeux auquel cas ça
brûle donc oui ce produit you de la
llagonne produits qui ont cassé d'un
vrai comme dangereux dans les gels et ce
qui s'est passé en fait en mars pendant
le confinement c'est que tous les
secteurs d'activité étaient en
difficulté et il ya plein de gens qui
faisait du business des petits malins
qui se sont dit bah tiens on va se
lancer dans la vente de masques de gel
et c'est donc les gens ont fabriqué
n'importe quel gel ont apporté dans
n'importe quel jeu il y en a qui l'ont
fait pour la bonne cause comme lvmh par
exemple mais donc du coup on a importé
n'importe quoi on en a vendu plein donc
oui je trouve ça scandaleux
qu'aujourd'hui du gène y en a partout et
on en met 15 fois par jour journée oui
mais alors là je pose une question où
est passé le stif les centaines
d'hectolitres hl d'alcool pur qu'on
donnez donnez donc fait cadeau les les
matches et je m'excuse se dire c'est bon
mais pernod ricard affiche cadeau pour
faire un lit gel hydroalcoolique de
centaines et centaines de litres
d'alcool oui somme où il est passé
la prochaine fois je vous pose la
question vous comme ça rigolo robert à
non mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que tout à l'heure vous avez dit la
chloroquine à tout le monde dans la
foulée depuis des années des années la
metal il faut un certificat médical en
riant rupture pourquoi si c'est pas pour
parce que ça j'aime les grands labos
accord par contre le coc vide et fait
pas partie du spis non mais bruno vous
voulez répondre au nez ou pas non non je
laisse penser ce qu'il veut et je
l'écouté c'est très bien vous allez au
lit rendre chaque fois vous avez vos
idées jeu
jamais moi je prie je peux dans mes
pages ou par le polyester hectolitres
d'alcool qui a été fait cadeau mais on
était il ya des bouteilles comme ça que
de laia palau
au début on n'avait pas la norme exact
on n'avait pas la composition exacte
pour faire c'est après qu'on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait des importations de
2 flacons de gel hydroalcoolique ou de
solution hydro alcoolique
oulala le pourcentage d'alcool n'était
pas fiable mais ça restait peut-être à
55% 50% ce qui n'est pas si grave mais
quand aujourd'hui l'étude c'est pas sur
la composent c'est sur la composition
peut-être mais aussi sur les rites
habilité il produire à force de se laver
les mains et pg hydro alcoolique peut
vous ruiner les yeux vous pouvez brûler
les mains faut hydrater il faut se
relève - je pensé qu'il était inefficace
jeudi dangereux parce que là c'est sur
les armes qu'on s'est désinfecté
c'est pas ça et que ça désespère pas et
qu'on touche à quelques notes finalement
c'est là que c'est michel vous allez
répondre sur la chloroquine note dans un
instant rodez ce que voulait dire juste
avant géraldine en ironie du soir une
histoire et d'histoire aussi le gel
hydro alcoolique il a été inventé par un
professeur jean en fait il a donné la
recette gracieusement à l'om s est donc
en fait il ne prend pas du tout d'argent
alors qu'il aurait pu prendre d'argent
ils auraient pu gagner des milliards et
des milliards mais il n'a pas voulu
d'accord il faut ça partait pour lutter
contre les maladies a d'ailleurs il ya
un pharmacien sur paris qui a fabriqué
des solutions hydro-alcooliques
avec cette formule pour pouvoir
justement les distribuer aux pharmaciens
pour puissiez voir sur la ne le
professeur abou audeh avait dit que le
gel hydro alcoolique était dangereuse il
ya quelques semaines il était quoi
qu'est le gel hydroalcoolique et
inefficace inefficaces ou une addition
fait que le gel des droits reconnus que
c'est inefficace
il avait les vices de l'interview il
suffit de mettre de l'eau de l'alcool et
ça suffit très largement
là c'est vrai que c'est un scandale
parce que on nous fait croire tout et
n'importe quoi pour le business
alors que les solutions miracles on l'a
sous la main ça s'appelle une savonnette
c'est moins cher
toute la journée
non mais tu sais moi je t'aime beaucoup
maxime est là moi ce que j'ai lu et
bruno vous me dites ainsi c'est juste
c'est que sur les mains on à la barrière
cutanée donc on a des bonnes et des
mauvaises bactéries et en fait ce gel il
a brûlé toutes les bactéries y rend la
peau friable et perméable et fragile et
c'est vrai que loin à force d'utiliser
trop de jal est vrai qu on le voit
d'ailleurs et des personnes qui ont les
mains un petit peu d'abonnés et il faut
séparer il faut il faut avoir une
hygiène et puis se laver les mains avec
un savon des cons aussi qu'on voulait
rentrer le soir alors ils ont justement
pour les téléspectateurs quels sont les
bons gel boulot dit la vérité vous qui
êtes pharmacien
les gels hydro-alcooliques c'est quoi ça
explosait dans votre chiffre d'affaires
ça doit être un truc de fou oui mais il
ya dix ans quand on a eu la chaîne 1 on
arrive on dit aussi des jeunes
alcooliques
non mais l'art du faux ça c'est un truc
de fou la saison en plus un tueur mais
aujourd'hui on a récupéré on retravaille
avec nos labos initial qui fabrique du
gel hydroalcoolique normés et vous ne
retrouvez plus de gel hydro alcoolique
avec des marques qui vienne où il faut
acheter du gel hydroalcoolique pour
l'élan parce que maintenant tout le
monde en veut donc man demain demain
vous allez à la boucherie
ils vont les vendre à noter deux
tranches de salami déjà déjà les
pharmaciens on a quand même un gel on
est surveillé par dix l'ont contraint de
rentrer dans le calamba si ils sont à
100 % en un an
100% d'accord du tout marché aussi les
prix sont laissés le sait et on n'a pas
de dépassement sur l'épée tout à fait
d'accord un jour michel boulet répondre
oui j'aurais pour la réunion parce qu'il
est faux cul c'est rené nommé raymond
ils sont tous les deux par est amusant
le chloroquine on veut l'interdire la
cour de route alors que ça marche depuis
40 ans honteux honteux ni pas clair de
baie comeau l'interdire c'est honteux
dit qu'on ne peut pas l'utiliser
on t'a jamais donc ce n'est pas un bon
produit sont des recettes parce que ça
marche il ya quatre ans il ya 40 ans sur
un autre m'a dit que ça marche
aujourd'hui son corps n'a et de quoi de
la chloroquine là ou là
on a rien qui me choque c'est pas parce
que ça marche et à 40 ans contre on m'a
dit que ça marche aujourd'hui contre le
contre le coran navires us
c'est tout ce qu'on sait c'est que mais
il a dit ce qu'il a dit ce matin aussi
il a dit comment se fait-il que l'état
ne finance pas des travaux sur les
alizés médicaments qu'ils puissent qui
pourrait également servir aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait voilà nous a sortis
encore ton truc son service militaire le
wagram et sofia sera une nouvelle
maladie on va chercher dans ce qu'on a
déjà dans notre panier donc on a il a
été chercher dans le clan qu'il y en a
d'autres qui recherchaient d'autres
médicaments et donc il a eu le mérite
d'essayer y en a d'autres qui ont sinon
il n'a pas pu continuer parce que l'état
n'a pas pu mener ses recherches
d'accord alors justement au bruno est ce
que les gels hydroalcooliques on trouve
dans l'effarement dans l'est dans les
parfumeries et oui comme ça est ce que
c'est fiable ou pas banal coliques on à
sa formule donc il n'ya pas de parfum
dans les célèbres alcoolique il ya des
failles il ya des compositions qui sont
pas normés tu là par exemple avec celui
qui ont les crocs d'un c est de la merde
alors alors allez-y
ben alors mais si la composition mais
vous allez je vous laisse aussi la
comparaison est plus de 60 % d'alcool
attendait alors je vous dis alors les
trucs des mais celui des chroniqueurs
alors où la composition 90 % d'origine
98 % d'origine naturelle mais ce que ces
salariés après la composition d'accord
un peu de jouer les races normalisante
rouge et je suis dans l'optique foot
mais pas les mystiques et fouillé mais
si des voix
non mais attendez alors moi je me dire
le bien le lien est un homme soit
hébergeant et target à l'eau pour cent
voilà donc bien sa magnifique 60% par un
cd c'est pas mal mais c'est et 110 73 %
à 60 % mais il ya un truc important
c'est que il vaut mieux même se laver
les mains avec un petit peu d'alcool où
il n'y a pas vraiment le vrai dosage
capture rien du tout ah oui donc oui et
ça mérite d'exister une amende de le
faire toi c'est bien mais pourquoi qui
en a qui disent que c'est dangereux non
utilisés sous produits excessif et demi
mais pourquoi il ya des autres bactéries
qui peuvent rentrer dedans moi j'ai lu
le staphylocoque par exemple qui est
quelque chose de très dangereux savane
enfin la cote sans le staphylocoque
c'est vrai ou pas ouais c'est vrai à la
coque avec des taux on est d'accord que
ça c'est une bataille qui est très
dangereuse et philo qui lui est si les
barrière cutanée sont brûlés ça rentre
dedans alors fatal n'a pas attendu ce
cas delphine si vous mettez un mauvais
gènes et peut avoir des déçus à la côte
dans ses nouvelles à raison le fait très
bien sûr oui oui bruno richard une
question y'a plein de distributeurs de
gel hydroalcoolique leur envie notamment
dans les arrêts de bus il y en a avec
ouais on actionne avec le pied là qu'on
actionne avec la main est ce que c'est
pas plus sales d'appuyer sur le gave sur
lequel tout m'ont amenée le frontal 200
soin de ma santé le contact tout à fait
il faut éviter le contact donc si vous
avez des distributeurs d'alcool sans
toucher quoi que ce soit et le liquide
tombe c'est toujours moi et voyez vous
dire puisque c'est un cercle vicieux ce
matin seuls au bureau je me suis lavé
les mains après une fois que monsieur
laver les mains j'ai refermé au c'est
moi qui paye l'eau vous imaginez bien
que je comprenais pas derrière le cinéma
temps j'ai touché donc j'ai rallumé
l'eau et après j'ai pris ainsi vous j'ai
remis avec après le chiffon était
mouillée si tu sais pas
sera totale ouais et après qu'est ce qui
fait j'ai été chercher du gel
hydroalcoolique
c'est un non mais là on devient fou ses
assistants qui ferment les robinets ou
non de bien rigoler un moment et à un
moment il faut avoir une hygiène une
distanciation il faut ça il faut se
surveiller
voilà après l'ex et eux sont tout excès
est mauvais et bien sûr un jaune et
s'essuyer les mains dedans alors avoir
des mauvais n&b pousse et ça c'est
important
on est les poussent et poussent les
doigts d'accord bien sur le bout des
doigts d'ailleurs j'ai vu twitter voilà
vous avez maison bleue très bien sûr et
ça vous permet de bien savoir où il faut
laver et ne pas hésiter même un petit
peu a dépassé aux essarts au niveau des
poignets
il faut bien compter 30 secondes
un minimum pour avoir les mains
parfaitement clean
merci